what's going on there reject nation we
are continuing gravity falls finally now
that the new place is set up
experimenting with some microphones
these are like microphone number 20 or
some random number like that before you
know we'll just have headsets that have
a mic in there and it's going to make
everything a lot easier not probably the
established form that we do anyway thank
you guys for being patient with us uh
but i'm excited to continue this series
like 13 14 more episodes left somebody
something like that all right well hey
guys leave a like if you can to be very
much appreciated also subscribe click
that notification bell to notify when
our next gravity falls reaction is up
and thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us add down these highlights
lastly full-length watch alongside sync
with the time code for gravity falls
along with a bunch of other shows that
we cover are over at our patreon page
become a super sexy reject today let's
check it out
[Music]
come in come in but be warned if you
enter you may be subjected to my tales
tales designed to sell my merchandise
[Laughter]
you've come to the mystery shack after
hours a time when only our creepiest and
most cursed objects are for sale like
that thing
yes
not a fan all right i can tell what
you're looking for is this disembodied
hand that's quite a tale and it's called
hands off
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
look at all these priceless treasures
acceptably masculine collectibles
professor glasses they make me look like
a genius
oh yeah oh gold beauties they're mob
boss quality
you could be a mob boss grunkle stan hey
hagface how much for the junk watches
they are not for sale not for you stan
pines oh whisper is your name
[Applause]
several chimes
less talking more watching
get your hands off my words
are you seriously shoplifting from a
witch that sounded like a curse that
sounded like a curse hey anyone want to
buy a wet blanket we got a wet blanket
for sale
ah white blanket
[Laughter]
curse yeah right
wait is this curse ugly or normal ugly
looks like i got off scot-free
[Music]
so i might have got cursed a little but
the watch looks nice right
foolish man leaving hands find a wicked
face
you must return what is it
[Applause]
i don't need hands i've got self-respect
mabel sweetie will you make your uncle
some hands
oh god oh god
oh god hello to your new hands in quotes
oh there's so many farts
[Laughter]
[Music]
should we play toss me a dozen eggs like
we always do wait not today
uncle stan did you just tap my shoulder
kid i can't tap anything
guys can you stop tapping both my
shoulders
[Applause]
[Music]
it's where things family is from
now can i have my hands back i have a
certain gesture i'd like to share with
you alas your hands cannot be gotten so
easily
spirits say
um
that the curse can only be broken by a
kiss
oh no oh no
i kiss on the lips what forget it i'm
not kissing any of that mess i don't
need my hands that bad oh boy
let's go kids no way don't go
you're right you're right i was just
making all that stuff up i was just
trying to get something going
so this was all just a ploy to get a
date but every time i bring someone back
here without keeping their hands hostage
they just run away
for example
a handlebar
that's a little creepy i'll take it hand
which likes then watch
[Music]
oh my goodness i can't believe this is
the same cave oh my goodness i just
can't find the words how about here's
your hands back
oh right
you guys are some handyman i've missed
you old rascals you're all right sister
will you be my boyfriend now nope never
well i learned
bye
i heard nothing i'm lost in these
mountains good eye crash here for the
night girl are those space pants because
your butt looks out of this world wow
thanks for noticing
solve this test of intelligence and your
photo could be on this box
what the heck a hedren
this is maymay and the hog coming at you
on am
whoa not sure we can say that on the air
don't touch that dial trucker's guzzle
grind it up and apply to the forehead
overnight
oh no
tomorrow i own you
this will go well
[Music]
whoa
i feel smarter already the digits of pi
are three point one
um four one five nine two six oh
snap dipper look
greetings friends it is i waddles the
pig
what the heck ahedron how did you do
that i can teach you dipper i can teach
you many things from the secrets of
astrophysics definitely right
man i am loving this new waddles yeah
he's uh
he's definitely uh
different oh no
a waddle don't you want to stay up here
and record some morning pranks with me
i'm sorry mabel there is more to life
than making fart noises and laughing at
those fart noises
oh
you guys
just go on without me
oh poor mabel here take this rocket pack
i invented and explore the heavens
yourselves forget that brenda's gonna
look at cute boys through skylights
oh yeah
i roll the sky
welcome to maymay in the hog a.m top
story today coping with crippling
loneliness after losing my co-host
loneliness oh yeah
mabel you are just in time to behold our
greatest achievement the smarticlex
will be able to solve all the greatest
puzzles of the universe the origin of
life the meaning of existence why dudes
have nipples
i'm your best friend i'm still your
friend mabel but i'm helping people now
don't you remember
us
remember those times
mabel you're holding him back from
greatness yeah
don't be so selfish what good is helping
the world if i can't help my favorite
person in the world it's a good thing i
built in a dum-dum switch oh no
[Music]
wow
pig
i want you to know that science is a
horizon to search for
no
our invention
just take the brain thing yourself man
oh yes
movies are great you watch the movie you
scare the girl the girl snuggles up next
to you next thing you know you gotta
raise a kid your life falls apart
clay day
oh my god
let's do it time you kids learn to watch
the classics from my day ooh old people
movies get ready for references we don't
understand and words we can't repeat
you're no match for going graphically
wow
wow
oh no mabel the cyclops his face is made
of nightmares
kid it's just a movie it can't hurt you
you see mabel those monsters are just
tiny clay figures moved around one frame
at a time by an anti-social shut-in
those people are called animators
[Laughter]
or claymore
we want to get a look at your figurines
we're not paparazzi
aha
hey
you
for the last time there is nothing here
to be afraid of that is crazy
oh god no let's escape by standing still
oh wow that is so cool
it is like a hairy housing movie do you
really believe someone moves these
figures one frame at a time i'm not a
masochist i used black magic to make
them animate themselves it was great at
first but one
oh
day
so real looking
where's the heart
[Music]
hey one night
yeah i'm talking to you dumb dumb come
at me
[Music]
no
this is creepy yeah
[Music]
wow how'd you do that so fast dang
the full body makeover that's right
because she believed in herself
creepy [ __ ]
so you're not scared anymore oh i'm
scared twice as much now stop motion is
pure evil i'm incredibly expensive
[Music]
today we learned that you can remold
your fears i'm just glad none of us got
turned into clay
[Music]
we're safe now kids
we're safe
i don't get it you don't want the pig
you don't want my tapes what are you
gonna buy
how about this delicious potion
here have a free sample
of course
should have bought my merch when you had
the chance buddy i'll have something new
for sale very soon
oh my god the legendary cheapskate
i saw it blinking
just an optical illusion come along
everyone step right up
no
[Music]
that's right i'm a jerk you're a
psychopath
hey i wanted to be exes let me be exes
yay
actually i'm sorry i changed my mind
i'll be yours
okay you're gonna hate me right now
i don't think you're playing this right
messed up mabel
yeah dude it's messed up man taking
advantage of a prisoner kidnap situation
right there that's horrifying that's it
uncle stan's evil yeah he's pure evil
prison somebody's drugged and imprisoned
somebody's evil man and is exploiting
them for for escapes
the sideshow
it is yeah but hey whatever it takes to
make a profit
a cheapskate could be any of us
capitalism
yes let's redux this
yes absolutely
stop at nothing
always the bottom line
all right john which one was your
favorite
um
pretty obvious contender for mwah
i mean are we both about to say the
claymation
okay on the count of three
one two three the claymation oh my god
how'd you know oh dude i don't know i
mean there are only three options to
crap you i don't know you
slapping that clay down smacking it
around kneading that stuff into shapes
yeah claymation's always been creepy as
hell to me claymation uh i mean uh yeah
it definitely can be other than chicken
run
that is an endearing claymation i think
that's the only claymation thing i've
ever seen that i'm like i really like
this movie really touched by the movie
but the other
every other claymation things always
kind of freaked me out oh yeah i mean a
little drummer boy in school gumby it's
always been weird
that's fair i mean yeah because there's
something about them where it's like
they're tangible things so you're like
oh that's
i know it's not alive but it could be
well i prefer for like the classic or
like was king kong claymation
stop motion yeah stop motion yeah uh
kong i i've i wasn't even kidding
emotion is the main word we should be
using because uh because at the end
there when they bring it it reminded me
of wow what's his name his name is
fourie
his name's forrest what's up john what's
you stupid yeah that teaches me my
attraction in my edition now which
his i forget his full name for e
something or other forest something or
other it'll come to me but he has this
well-renowned sort of uh collection of
various movie props and things and he
has one of the original king kong
armatures
uh with some of the original you know
skin and fur on it and i have actually
been blessed enough to hold that and and
to like pose it a little bit um so you
know
that was actually like yeah a metal
armature with stuff on it this might
have been my favorite of the claymation
of the the claymation the anthology my
favorite claymation gravity falls up
yeah out of the three
yeah yeah yeah uh out of the anthologies
is probably my favorite one of them uh
i prefer gravity falls generally when
it's
you know like more of a serialized
storytelling
but the anthology stuff is fun this is
like their own especially this one
it's like their own version of like a
treehouse of horror from simpsons meats
uh you know tales from the crypt
obviously which i really liked i like
that they put it in this first person
point of view kind of um what's the word
i'm looking for here it's not
kind of like a video game in a way but
uh
yeah i mean it's it's
pov it's almost like a found footage but
not well yeah they put you in the
the perspective of be that's what makes
it feel like a video game like you're
choosing you're not really choosing
so the horrific horrors that are so
horrific when santa did the guy at the
end i'm like this guy puts a whole new
light of the character in my eyes yeah
he did literally drug and and and uh
imprisoned that person and is now using
them as an exhibit the psychotic kids
dipper and mabel don't even care yeah
and we are them we we are the cheapskate
we are the cheapskates that's what we're
called i like the meta commentary on the
animation we've seen chip and dale
rescue rangers this year now this
episode of gravity falls which both take
their opportunities as animators to go
out of their way to make commentary on
animation mediums in the
industry yeah fun stuff but the first
two were cute um i liked the hands-off
one a lot
uh it didn't really really have a lesson
to it not really i don't know just kind
of oh she just needed to redo her place
yeah i thought they could have gone a
little bit more horrific with it they
could have i mean i respect them
building to that but yeah i thought they
could have maybe done some truly witchy
stuff with that yeah um but i enjoyed it
i thought it was pleasant it's funny i
actually by the end because i liked the
mood of the wrap around uh by the end
weirdly i was like i like this wrap
around a lot even though it is mostly
just interstitial stan just setting up
what he's about to do like for whatever
reason i didn't actually expect it to
pay off and turn into a story unto
itself and so that one took me by
surprise the most yeah yeah fair enough
but yeah i i liked the aesthetic i
thought there were a lot of fun really
goofy sight gags and names of things in
the hands off one especially but but
yeah these were i think these were
placed well because hands-off would be
like my second favorite and the wattles
one like it's fun to have neil degrasse
tyson i i found that perfectly enjoyable
and pleasant but it is sort of the
the least uh you know sort of
invigorating i guess of the three well
it doesn't really go too far either yeah
and then it's sort of he starts building
stuff and then doesn't yeah and it's
like you know what i prefer my simple
life of
piggery of love and friendship and all
that
not succumbing to your own what was i
like the lesson that neil degrasse tyson
waddles pointed out what was it about
sciences uh
oh yeah it's a horizon to chase not a
thing to hold true true yeah which hey
it's it's funny i was listening to a
wisecrack video the other day about
what they call thought leaders and neil
degrasse tyson came up with in that and
it was sort of about that uh the way in
which uh scientists and philosophers can
kind of become co-opted by
you know um
the speaker industry and things like
that and the
thought leader industry to kind of go to
that place of holding the science rather
than chasing the horizon of the science
and all the different contributing
factors to that so it was interesting
that that he should actually you know
put such a succinct kind of button on
that in this
it's kind of like scoopers
who said it first who leaked it first
who got that first piece of information
out there that toby mcguire and andrew
garfield were going to be in spiderman
no way information commodities yeah yeah
yeah and then you're selling you're
selling a specific kind of information
that you're mining
yeah now science is political
isn't that great loving that funny i
love it
yeah there is no objective anything
anymore god no everything is subjective
um but yeah i thought this was a really
fun one i think out of the anthologies
this is probably the most i was
interested in all the ones that they
were doing
um
and i like that each one had a different
focus of a main character first one was
uncle stan second one was um i mean they
were both i think the second one and the
third one both kind of share dipper and
mabel now that i think about it yeah
but i like the i like the the lesson
learned a lot in the claymate i feel
like that is just hands down the
strongest one beyond whatever biases we
have towards the claymation uh it is
still the strongest one even the lesson
of like learning you can mold your fears
i think that's such a great i've never
heard that phrase before i don't know if
it's an actual phrase
i think though that is something that
would probably stick with me as a life
lesson of like learning because i'm
someone who's often like yeah go after
your fears and then learning to mulch
your fears so not necessarily about not
being afraid but how to work with your
fears
or um reshape them in some way it's like
i was having a conversation with someone
the other day about
um
because i i struggle a lot with anxiety
and anxiety being uh
uh
there's ways people respond to anxiety
differently and i've learned to respond
to anxiety in a way of
get it done
where some people kind of hit walls or
um
get stilted or frozen
and that's not to like credit myself
better because it's just how i used to
be and it's not healthy i'm not saying
like if you have anxiety yeah lean into
it it's not healthy like it doesn't make
me feel good uh but i have learned to
become someone who's like i'm feeling
anxious what's the best way to relieve
this just get the thing done that i'm
anxious about but sometimes it keeps me
up all freaking night because i'm just
anxious so it's definitely not a healthy
thing uh
so but there are times where molding the
anxiety is what can often get stuff
accomplished here
and in a more efficient manner or to get
it
up quicker to you guys or something like
that you know or to like ah we're having
a major problem here i'm feeling anxious
about it uh how do i convert this energy
into focus so that's that's sometimes
that's when it becomes good and usually
the anxiety stems from a fear of
something so that's why i'm kind of
relating to it on a much smaller level
here either way this was a really fun
episode i enjoyed it wonderful mixture
of animation styles uh throughout beyond
the claymation i think they really
i like what i liked about the anthology
spread is that they each felt like a
different type of animation to a certain
extent even if it's more subtle than
others it was cool that they managed to
sort of weave in and out of different
genres and tones and lighting palettes
and whatnot so yeah thank you guys for
being here what was your favorite of the
anthologies
anyhow subscribe click that bell should
probably do a patreon
david gandy we are now wearing the
gravity falls here there you go
this is a makeup for that because we
still need to unpack the gravity falls
gears the last step we'll know that the
office is fully complete when david
gandy's hats grace the tops of our heads
again david
if there's anybody at patreon who i
would love to be entrapped in a glass
case by it's you i feel like i would be
in good hands you know as much as that's
not what i necessarily envisioned for
the rest of my life you know being held
up as some kind of
exhibit for you to profit off of at the
same time you know i would feel good
that i'm helping you you know grow the
foundations of your life maybe attract
more people toward yourself so that you
can you know grow your network of people
who you know
who love you and who can come to you for
guidance or opportunity for
entertainment or whatever it might be
this camera david gandy it's all cause
of you bro yeah so like
like i feel like at this point you
deserve at least one of us as payment
because we can never repay you for all
the time love and attention that you've
given us
um yeah i'm just gonna put myself in a
box out on the curb and if you wanna
come pick me up you know you put
position me however you want you know do
whatever you want
uh david i give you full permission so
i've got contracts signed up i'm gonna
sign away my life to you and uh we're
gonna start something holy fresh and new
and uh i'm i'm excited
buddy so
hey you're in my ears john and yeah
i don't think i listened to a word
that's all right that's um that's that's
the ideal i think that's that's probably
how people should take that from me
thank you david for being here buddy
[Music]